ali reza probably leaning back
got himself some fresh coffee and is
ready to squeeze for another
hour or two i'm not sure why the coffee
drinker at the age of 17
you drink coffee is it is did the kids
i don't know actually valley resort
drinks coffee
because actually i never ever in my life
ever tasted coffee so i
even don't know what it tastes yeah it's
just incredible but i was you know
because
i was like the tea kind and i somehow
got into the tea business
and and never never ever tried coffee
we take it one step at a time with you
you got a phone now that's a great
achievement for the last 10 years
we'll we'll start coffee and cigarettes
and in the distant future not yet yeah
well but no i don't think you're missing
much it's just another addiction no i
don't think
the taste is like anything people are
saying oh
this is so tasty my my morning coffee
but do you like tea honestly because yes
i like tea yeah i
i have all these special chinese teas
and whenever i go to china you know
i'm bringing all these wonderful lovely
teas and
i'm enjoying it a lot